[Music]
on this saturday night
the escalating fight in nova scotia a
suspicious fire at a lobster facility
we view it as a hate crime will the
federal government intervene in the
battle between indigenous and commercial
fissures
kofit 19 benefits in limbo lots of long
delays people
very frustrated more problems with the
government agency distributing
badly needed funds the surging copin 19
numbers
in the u.s every part of the nation is
going to be lit up by infection
and the controversial call for herd
immunity
plus how europe is trying to manage
travel and keep the pandemic
in check
good evening and thank you for joining
us there is a disturbing development in
the escalating violence of an indigenous
lobster fishery in nova scotia
a lobster pound being used by migma
fishers
has been completely destroyed by fire
this is all that's left of the facility
investigators are calling the fire
suspicious one man
considered a person of interest by the
rcmp is in hospital
with critical injuries it happened near
the southern tip of nova scotia at one
of the two sites raided by commercial
fishers this week
public safety minister bill blair just
released a statement saying
the temperature of this dispute must be
lowered now
the threats violence and intimidation
have to stop
blair has approved extra rcmp support in
nova scotia
but as ross lord reports indigenous
leaders say the federal government
should have stepped in weeks ago
in these images the pattern of violence
surrounding the nova scotia lobster
fishery
takes a harrowing leap forward a lobster
pound
used by indigenous fishers to store
their catch set ablaze
in what rcmp call a suspicious act was
the worst fire i've been in the fire
department for 40 years since the worst
fire i ever seen
like it was the heat was so intense that
he couldn't go anywhere near and it was
hard to fight
i heard like the crackling noises and as
soon as i heard that i totally knew what
it was
so i looked out the window and i could
see like orange orange glow and i woke
my husband up
and they're burning it down rcmp say a
man is in hospital with what they call
life-threatening injuries
they say the man is a person of interest
in the fire investigation
it's disgusting and i can't imagine
how or why
they would target it like that cops
can't even control these guys
and there's a lot of them lobster pound
was the center of violence tuesday night
when an indigenous fisher who brought
his lobsters there for storage
was forced to barricade himself inside
while angry commercial fissures
removed his catch commenting on the fire
and the severe injuries that ensued
sebago negative chief mike sack is
taking the high road
still haven't heard lately on how the
guy was making out there but i hope
there's a full recovery and
we had remorse for everyone involved and
we viewed as a hate crime it was
directed towards people that we
we do business with and it's very
unfortunate a supreme court ruling 21
years ago
upheld indigenous fishers right to earn
a so-called moderate livelihood
outside of regular seasons but
commercial fishers insist
all harvesters should be subject to the
same seasonal rules
with each violent episode calls for
peace become more
urgent assembly of first nations
national chief perry belgaard
is demanding a full and thorough
investigation by the proper authorities
for several weeks indigenous leaders and
commercial fishery reps
have been urging federal politicians and
agencies
to help bring an end to escalating
violence
the aftermath of this fire might give
those warnings extra meaning so
it just reaffirms what we've been asking
for you know there needs to be more law
enforcement in the area
more safety rcmp have announced charges
against a man
for allegedly assaulting chief sack in
connection with an altercation wednesday
investigations continue into a slew of
other incidents including this
the most troubling episode yet ross lord
global
west public nova scotia canadians
looking to apply for most coven 19
benefits or
even check the status of their
applications are out of luck this
weekend
the canada revenue agency is doing what
it calls routine maintenance it's
happening at a time when many canadians
are already having trouble getting the
help they need
abigail beeman reports we regret the
inconvenience
disappointing jordan rhaego was getting
the serb
now he's applied for the new canada
recovery benefit the application process
opened monday and he's had no luck just
an error message
it doesn't provide me any information as
to why i'm ineligible
there is not even a follow-up from that
error message that's provided
to applicants who apply online where you
know what the next steps are if they
have to call
which department to call and yes
from what i understand i am eligible
he's dealt with dropped calls and long
wait times and he's not alone hundreds
posting their frustrations with the
system in this facebook group
making things worse no one can apply for
any of the three new benefits right now
the cra site and phones down for a full
weekend for routine system maintenance
the cra wouldn't comment on the timing
of this outage but told global news in a
statement
some applications are not immediately
approved and in these cases individuals
are receiving messages to call the cra
this is because the cra is performing
more upfront verification
to help ensure that crb payments are
being issued to individuals who are
eligible
rhaego says he was never told to call
anyone so far the cra said it processed
more than 876 thousand applications for
the three new benefits
the others are the canada recovery
sickness benefit and the canada recovery
caregiving benefit
almost six hundred thousand of those
were for the crb
it hasn't said how many more people are
having issues applying
if they had extended serb at least until
after the scheduled maintenance
the people who right now are calling in
trying to get a hold
can't get a hold of anyone while they
are worried about being able to keep
food on the table
being able to pay for rent you know this
is totally unacceptable
opposition mps say they've been getting
lots of calls and emails too
but conservatives blame the liberals for
proroguing parliament
delaying the process we would have had
at least six additional weeks to beta
test
make sure we had all these programs but
as it was unfortunately the government
put the civil service in a very
difficult position and that's left
canadians behind
it's been challenging to say the least
the cra tells global news that
only this thursday did it begin sharing
applicant data daily with the different
government department that handles ei
the error code rego and many others
received is related to this
it's 0-2-6 and the cra says anyone who
got
that code should try to reapply again on
monday
abigail beeman global news ottawa
quebec has broken another record for new
coven 19 cases
the province says 1279 people tested
positive in the last 24 hours
that surpasses a previous daily high set
on october 2nd
ontario is reporting 805 new cases today
that's the sixth straight day of new
cases above 700
in that province copen 19 cases in the
u.s are
surging at an alarming rate with
hospitals in several states getting
increasingly overwhelmed
the country has reported more than 8
million cases since the pandemic began
but 1 million of those were in the past
three weeks
president donald trump who was
hospitalized with coven 19
is carrying on with tightly packed
campaign events
including a stop today in hard hit
wisconsin
jennifer johnson reports new infections
of cobit 19 are surging in almost
every u.s state but more concerning to
health officials
the rapid spike in hospitalizations at
least a dozen states are seeing
all-time highs in patients being
admitted for covet 19.
i think that as we enter the fall in the
winter every part of the nation is going
to be lit up by infection
florida which is almost completely
reopened just recorded its highest death
toll in 24 hours
survivors like deanna hare who spent 196
days in a michigan
hospital are proof of how brutal the
virus can be
i was unconscious for about
two and a half months my life and our
lives have
been changed forever in parts of
wisconsin
icu beds are at 90 percent capacity the
state's positivity rate has hit 25
percent
the white house coronavirus task force
is urging residents to avoid large
crowds
but u.s president donald trump has
refused to cancel a rally in janesville
wisconsin saturday night
as democratic presidential candidate joe
biden continues to attack trump's
handling of the pandemic
white house officials are defending
their actions well the president is out
and about the task forces meeting each
and every day
we have our doctors out on the airwaves
we have our doctors out in local media
addressing these communities
directly in minnesota at least 20 cases
of the virus have been linked to a trump
rally last month
in georgia pictures have emerged of
tight maskless crowds
helping a state representative crowdsurf
at a trump rally friday night
doctors fear americans have grown tired
of taking precautions which are more
important than ever as winter approaches
there's nothing magical about six feet
inside and so if you're six feet apart
and
have your face masked off you're still
at risk of getting the virus or
transmitted to somebody else
as the weather gets colder more people
are gathering inside
adding even more fuel to a pandemic that
has already infected over
8 million americans jennifer johnson
global news
washington the pandemic has changed
so much in our lives including the
freedom to travel
since the spring european union nations
have implemented
varying rules on who can enter each
country without going into quarantine
now as redmond shannon reports the
countries have agreed on a new common
policy
to deal with rapidly changing infection
rates across the continent
covid19 has cut international air travel
by 60 percent
in europe that's partly down to the
ever-changing mishmash of
travel rules that differ across the
continent
confusing even for experienced flyers
like travel blogger
james lorraine had to look three ways we
kind of to watch what the
uk travel corridors were going to be
then see if the scottish ones were going
to be any different
and then uh see what countries
were still allowing allowed along the uk
citizens on
but seven months into the pandemic and
the eu has finally decided to
standardize the rules
today's agreement is a welcome
improvement to
a currently precarious situation the new
traffic light system will allow
passengers from low infection
green regions to be allowed to travel
without isolating
coming from orange and red regions will
require passengers to self-isolate or
to provide a negative test the eu admits
some details
need to be ironed out we will continue
to work with member states on better
coordination of testing
and quantile requirements currently none
of the
31 participating countries have a
nationwide case rate low enough to be
classified as green
and just a handful have regions that are
deemed safe
so the system will require passengers
flying from airports in green regions to
be honest about where they actually
live a standardized passenger
declaration form is also
in the works but despite these new
measures case rates can change
quickly i've been booking really kind of
last minute
my flight to germany was eight o'clock
in the morning
and i booked at i think it was about 6
30 the night before passengers traveling
from canada to
some european countries do not need to
isolate on arrival
but the canadian government still
advises against all
non-essential travel redmond shannon
global news london
police in france say an 18 year old of
chechen origin
is responsible for the gruesome killing
of a teacher the country's
anti-terrorism squad says the young man
waited for the victim outside a school
in a paris suburb
and asked students to help identify him
47-year-old samuel patty was stabbed
several times and then beheaded police
shot and killed the attacker a short
distance away from
the scene patty had been the target of
threats after showing students
caricatures of the prophet muhammad
during a lesson on freedom of expression
the teen was born in moscow but moved to
france as a refugee when he was a child
his parents and other members of his
family have been taken into police
custody
for questioning tonight armenia and
azerbaijan will attempt another truce
for humanitarian reasons after three
weeks of fighting over the disputed
region of nagorno-karabakh
earlier today azerbaijan blamed armenia
for the deaths of at least 13 civilians
in a missile attack on a residential
neighborhood in the city of ganja
more than 40 others were injured armenia
denies it's responsible for the strike
the two former soviet republics agreed
to a cease-fire one week ago
but within hours that fell apart at
least 700 people have been killed
since the conflict erupted serious
allegations tonight from a hong kong
pro-democracy protester alexandra wong
says chinese authorities kept her in
custody for a month and a half
and barred her from returning to hong
kong for nearly 14 months
she alleges she suffered mental abuse
and was interrogated almost every day
while in detention the 64 year old had
been a familiar face at anti-government
protests in hong kong
before she vanished in august 2019.
coming up how new zealand's prime
minister has become one of the most
popular world leaders
tonight new zealand's prime minister is
celebrating an historic election win
with all votes counted jacinda ardern's
liberal labor party won
49 of the vote compared to 26.8 percent
for the main challenger
the party has sealed an outright
majority in parliament something that
hasn't happened
since new zealand implemented
proportional voting 24 years ago
typically parties must form alliances to
govern but this time
ardern and her party can go it alone
we will not take your support for
granted
and i can promise you we will be a party
that governs for every
new zealander our plan is already in
action and
already working but after this result
we have the mandate to accelerate our
response
and our recovery and tomorrow we start
ardern is well known around the world
which is unusual for a leader of this
peaceful nation
of just under 5 million people her
popularity
soared earlier this year when she led a
successful effort to
crush the spread of covet 19. it was a
go hard
and go early approach but it hasn't
always been easy for ardern
mike delay takes a look at her political
rise
jacinda mania was born from moments like
this we're just having a bit of an
earthquake here ryan
quite a quite a decent shake here not
even a 5.8 earthquake seems to rattle
new zealand's prime minister
and to think jacinda ardern is still
relatively new to the political scene
[Music]
she was first elected in 2017 in an
election she was supposed to lose in a
landslide
what a difference three years makes i
will make whatever new zealand voters
deliver
work but can she her first term was
marred by broken election promises
and her popularity began to wane until a
series of events thrust her into the
spotlight
shortly after being elected she became
only the second woman in modern history
to give birth
while in power yes i can do the job and
be a mother
she took a little time off returning to
become a leading voice on climate change
actually this is about being on the
right side of history
and when a lone gunman killed 51
worshipers at a pair of christchurch
mosques
she immediately promised action i can
tell you one thing right now
our gun laws will change and while she
joined her country in grieving the dead
she pushed through tough gun laws many
thought impossible
we will close our border to any
non-residents and citizens
she was as decisive in dealing with the
pandemic closing new zealand's borders
to foreigners
in february and after a strict lockdown
announced in june the country
had effectively wiped out covet 19. i
did a little dance
now the hard work begins for the leader
dubbed the anti-trump
mike turley global news toronto
saving or costing lives still ahead the
immunity issue
splitting scientists
in a pandemic herd immunity is the holy
grail the point at which enough people
are immune to protect those who are not
it can come from a protective vaccine
or after enough people get infected now
a controversial declaration by a group
of scientists suggests
almost all schools and businesses around
the world should reopen
to expedite immunity from covet 19.
other eminent researchers are aghast at
an idea
they say would cost more lives eric
sorenson reports
when president trump encourages crowds
to gather without requiring masks or
distancing
he is in effect promoting a strategy to
speed up transmission of the novel
coronavirus
to achieve herd immunity sooner it
happens people have it and it goes
get the kids back to school we got to
get the kids back to school
the approach would drop restrictions and
allow the virus to run through the
younger stronger population
while protecting the elderly and
vulnerable white house officials have
cited the barrington declaration
signed by dozens of doctors stating in
part those who are not vulnerable should
immediately be allowed to resume
life as normal this canadian doctor
co-signed the petition
i would like to see healthy young people
get back to work because they're very
low risk
uh of coppova 19. the central point of
the declaration is that lockdowns have
the potential
to cause harms not really related to
cobit 19.
harms such as delayed medical attention
for other illnesses
and mental health problems from social
isolation i think that this plan would
cause far
fewer people to die overall once you
take into account
suicides from unemployment but a wave of
international researchers has responded
with
alarm to the idea that the vulnerable
can be cordoned off from young people
as they acquire immunity writing in the
lancet it is a dangerous fallacy
unsupported by scientific evidence we
are an incredibly
interconnected society and
intergenerational society
so for this uh you know notion that we
can
in some artificial way segregate
generations it's utterly ridiculous
manaus brazil has been cited as a
real-time example where herd immunity
developed
after a tragic number of covet 19 deaths
there was evidence the population had
achieved a level of immunity around 50
percent or higher
the beaches opened up life largely
returned to normal
but recently cases of covet 19 have
surged once more
and researchers have raised the
possibility that immunity the antibodies
after infection
may not last this is a disease or an
infection that
hasn't been around for a year and so we
have no idea about
its uh the durability of immunity after
having been infected
the world health organization is adamant
that trying for herd immunity before
there's a vaccine
would do more harm than good never in
the history of public health has heard
immunity been used as a strategy for
responding to an outbreak
allowing a dangerous virus that we don't
fully
understand to run free is simply
unethical
there's no modern playbook to ameliorate
the health social and economic harm from
covid19
and absent a vaccine there are no easy
answers
eric sorensen global news toronto
up next how an ontario man is helping
keep a sweet tradition
safe
[Music]
halloween is in two weeks and a toronto
plumber is helping families
slide into the spooky season safely
these candy shoots are making
trick-or-treating possible while
physically distancing
jeff burke saw the idea online and
decided to make them
in exchange for donations to the food
bank
so i'm in a couple of the neighborhood
facebook groups around here
and uh one saturday morning i posted it
on a few of these groups
and yeah within two days we had more
than 400 responses we had to shut it
down
it's no wonder the shoots are in high
demand according to stats canada
over 4 million kids between the ages of
5 and 14 go trick-or-treating for
halloween
in october 2018 canadians spent over 630
million dollars on treats 11 percent of
those sales were for personal
consumption
but here's the scary part canadians
spend more per capita on costumes
candy and decor than americans making
halloween
the most expensive holiday after
christmas
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is edmonton thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here
tomorrow have a great night
you